[Music]
[Applause]
the ftth council Europe today presented
its outstanding contribution to the
acceleration of ftth in Europe award to
uk-based Giga Clare I'm delighted to be
joined by the company's chief executive
Matthew hare
Matthew thanks for joining us and
congratulations on the award I've got to
ask you you know how did it feel when
that your name came out O'Brien
thank you very much for saying and it
was fabulous obviously I mean what a
great recommendation
what a great acknowledgement of what
we've managed to do in the UK with Giga
clear and and fantastic that we've been
picked out from all of the people from
from Estonia to Belarus who could have
been picked and they picked us fabulous
thanks very much no it's great and the
UK does have some unique challenges tell
us about some of the hurdles you've
overcome since you started I think 2010
yeah we started in 2010 just me on my
own so you know really came from nothing
and and we've now built up to a business
of of over 200 people over 15,000
customers and the challenges have been
you know really down to how do you
finance an infrastructure business from
from the ground up with you know from
nothing how do you you know build a
market position where where people are
willing to trust you with their their
broadband and and they've never heard of
Giga clear I mean they have now and and
of course with this award that I've
heard heard of it even more but but they
hadn't heard of us at all to begin with
and then it's actually the operational
issues of you know actually building new
infrastructure has comes with a whole
series of challenges because bluntly you
have to dig up all the roads yes are you
saying that now they've heard of you
what's the kind of Nick step where do
you go from here well there's just an
awful lot more to do so there's 13
million properties in the UK of which
about half a million only have have full
fibre right now of which we do about 10%
so you know honestly there's the other
29 and a half billion properties to
build we only do rural so we only do the
rural bits
that still leaves you with you know five
or six million properties that are
improperly rural areas that we could be
serving that right now nobody's giving
them five or two so it's just a lot more
of the same I know that's slightly
boring repeat repeat repeat but that's
what we're going to do and in the
process of what you've discovered and
the experiences that you've been through
is there anything that you would say to
our colleagues in Europe trying to do
the same thing with rural areas yeah I
mean there are some great opportunities
with rural that are very different to
urban I mean it does cost more to build
these networks but the enthusiasm of the
of the people who live in and work in in
rural areas is massive because they they
honestly generally feel very left behind
by pretty much any other technical
development and if you take fiber into
their home or into their business you
know your catapulting them right to the
front of the queue and and they love it
so you know they are very loyal they are
very enthusiastic they are really keen
to help and that you need to harness
that while at the same time bearing in
mind you know this is a commercial
endeavor so you need to be focused on
making sure you you're building
infrastructure it's going to be there
for a long time that investors are keen
on supporting okay well congratulations
again and thanks for talking to us
thank you very much prime so
award-winning Giga clear bringing a lot
of satisfaction out in those rural areas
in Europe
[Music]
you